the Joe Rogan experience you know before
night no this is such a cool thing so
all the car companies all the car
companies used to use spray paint or
like manually for the different cars
right so over the years you'd have
layers of this paint and it became
basically an artificial mineral so when
you take a cross-section it looks like
here why don't I give you them a nice so
yeah for tight right you have these car
companies car car plants so they're
spray painting the Ford truck black the
next year to read the next year it's
green over time the painting cute
accumulates and you can use that cross
section to make really cool things oh
wow yeah look up for die Jamie looks
really really good a jeweler aning
yellow oh that's real yeah that's from a
car that's what a car plant because look
every year it's a different color it's a
really cool substance I got a couple of
four date pens warthog tusks that's
crazy
wooden one from the DMZ yeah Wow
is that amazing that's really cool yeah
I never heard of that before
and so one more time they're taking it
out of like a Ford plant or a Corvette
Bryant or whatever every one of Corvette
went a Ford and over the years you know
they'd ship it away from the walls
mm-hmm and they have a block of it here
you go give that thick yeah Wow and you
can do whatever you want with it
including makeup attorneys and [ __ ]
cool right that's like a cool form of a
fossil or something or it's like an
industrial fossil yeah this is cool cuz
I got the layer it's like tree rings
almost and so you have a pen made out of
that I've got to oh you lucky devil yeah
you sent me one for free
so how do people know that you're you're
into pens oh so I do something called
spike funding right so what happens on
Twitter is every so often some [ __ ]
will come for me
and I'll be like it would be a shame if
people send me money to waste on things
I don't want just to spite you and I put
up Michael Mouse comm contribute and I
go I will post receipts and people send
me cash and they say this has to be
wasted so I buy I don't need seven pens
I don't need eight shaving brushes I
don't need a signed copy of Langston
Hughes's book I got them fossils and
this is all because of
[ __ ] ya sons after you on Twitter and
I'm like okay people gonna sit and then
they go oh you know you're a snake oil
salesman I'm like no no no no one's
getting anything out of this except for
spite in you I don't really need these
things I don't let that make you a snake
oil sales cause they're like oh you're
conning these people out of money
they're like no no it's all understood
this is total waste of money just to
[ __ ] with you well they definitely don't
know what snake oil is then ya know what
why are you engaging with people on
Twitter you're a smart guy because it's
fun enjoy it
it's hilarious it's my biggest activity
really in clowning idiots yes you're
number one thing it's - I'm really fun
with it and I'm really good with it I've
started doing a little bit of psyops on
Twitter too so yeah so like for example
what I've been doing is a lot of these
people these candidates they're like
press secretary will have fewer
followers than me right so I'll say
something like hey there was an article
in The New York Times today about your
candidate how freaked out is the
campaign and how much is this a
reflection on you not being able to do
your job correctly because you know when
that article hits the New York Times
you're in the campaign you're in the
bunker you're freaking out what does
this mean so to have if someone's like
[ __ ] you they give like no [ __ ] you so
you do this even if there's not a real
story well if there's a story
oh because you know they're in full
panic okay so when they're in full panic
then you attack yeah for fun and cuz
they're bad people often which ones are
bad Jeremy Corbyn and Cal Harris those
are the two I thought were the worst
other than that I don't think anyone's a
bad person who's the Corbin guy again
what he he's court wouldn't in labor
right what's the name again Jeremy
Corbyn yeah what does he do he was the
head of the Labour Party in the UK
that's right okay just had the biggest
disaster election since 1935 worse
that's right he he my favorite thing he
did was he said his pronouns oh yeah I
said my pronouns are he/him yeah yeah
yeah I did this video my name is Jamie
Corbin Jeremy Corbyn yeah whatever the
[ __ ] it is Elizabeth Warren has her
pronouns on her thank God for us yeah
well this is signaling that you're part
of the tribe yes yeah you're willing to
believe in nonsense that [ __ ] is 150
years old she knows what her [ __ ]
pronouns are mum and mummy come on with
this not
sense your pronouns are what's your name
is it Elizabeth you're late you're a
lady right come on well in her defense -
in her defense Warren is a man's name so
it's not fair
oh yeah it's so stupid it's so stupid
[Applause]